Life is a tomato right off the vine.
With the popularity of tomato-based dishes throughout parts of Europe,...
...one would imagine it's enjoyed a long, celebrated history across the continent...
...at very least, in Spain and Italy.
That would be no and primarily for two reasons.
One is that the tomato didn't even get there until the early 1500s.
It finally arrived thanks to some conquistadors,...
...people can't agree on which ones who brought it back from Mesoamerica.
Some European gardeners dabbled with them for ornamental purposes,...
...but foodwise they weren't a popular item.
The second is the hit taken to their image...
...because of their perceived involvement in the deaths of upper class Europeans by the late 1700s.
Even though history later cleared its reputation,...
...for a long time it was blamed when lead poisoning was actually the culprit.
The tomato's acid leached lead from their pewter plates...
...and it ended up being consumed in dangerous quantities.
The Italians were among the first to accept it,...
...as it grew so well in their climate.
The world didn't follow suit until the pizza was invented in Naples in mid to late 1800s.
By the 20th century its time had finally come...
...and it became a staple in soups, sauces, and salads.